[Music]
so without further ado
2035 tony l-103 okay let's go with a one
e4
and let's play something very aggressive
let's see if we can go for checkmate
this game
all right he goes e6
all right so i guess we'll start with d4
okay assume he's going to play d5
yeah
and
i can play many different weapons here
i'm going to play a line that i think
flies quite a bit under the radar
i named this line after peter
um
but it's it's one of those lines that
has existed for many years but isn't
talked about much i think it's
originally named after stein it so it
starts as an advance i'm going to push
e5
and here everybody and their brother
goes c3 which seems
extremely natural i mean what else could
you possibly do it seems unthinkable to
give this pawn away and yet that's
exactly what i'm gonna do
we're going to pretend that nothing is
happening and go knight f3
uh looks absurd okay he goes knight c6
he doesn't take immediately again
we have the opportunity to play c3
but instead we're going to keep
developing as if nothing is happening
bishop d3 inviting him to take this pawn
this is not an easy line to explain
and i'll attempt to do that more deeply
after the game
the bottom line is that you let black
take the pawn and you focus instead on
maintaining the e5 pawn
because the e5 pawn is the one that's
really clamping down on black's position
so what you do
is you accelerate your development
you leave this pawn untouched you
quickly put a rook on e1 and you focus
on fast development and on the
maintaining of the pawn on e5 bishop d7
okay so this guy is actually not
playing this conventionally he's not
taking the pawn on d4
uh which is pretty rare
and
we can i mean we can't play c3 but that
wouldn't be in the spirit of the line we
can even take on c5
but that would help black develop his
bishop which is not necessarily
desirable
so for now i propose that we
for now i propose that we make
essentially healthy waiting moves if
that makes sense so
we'll start with the move rookie one to
defend the pawn e5
this is called over over protection
we're making sure this pawn is going to
be super well protected
in case the pawn on d4 is captured which
i imagine it will be
rook c8 would be pretty good here i
think just not taking the pun at all
but we want him to take it so i can
demonstrate the main ideas of the line
thank you gus 1787.
yeah we'll end after this game
okay he's thinking
he's thinking i mean black has many
alternatives he can go c4 which would
plan into our hands because it would
leave the d4 pawn essentially untouched
knight h6
all right
all right
that is a very typical french move as
i'm sure you guys know the knight is
heading for f5
we do not want to take this knight
that's a very bad idea
uh for for many reasons this bishop is
actually very important in the french
also the b2 pawn will be left very weak
we do want to keep this bishop alive
um
so
one way that we can play this
this night on b1 in the french in this
line of the french rarely goes to c3 the
problem with the knight going to c3 is
that it blocks the c pawn
and it invites him to take on d4 with
tempo which we don't really want
so as
an as as weird as this move looks
knight b to d2 actually strikes me as
quite interesting
so that's one alternative
another alternative is to play c3 now
and claim that we have an improved
version of an advanced thank you dr lord
mayonnaise
on the other hand
if we go knight c3
and he takes on d4
that knight could head to b5 and from
there it could go to d6 and try to root
out this bishop so when i look at it
more deeply
i actually like the move knight c3 we're
going to play it
thank you dr lord mayonnaise for the 10
gifted subs much appreciate it
so does that make sense this knight
looks very awkward it looks like we're
inviting c64 but i spotted this b5 score
for the night
from where it could head to d6 so i
think
this is a justified violation of the
rule
rarely do you play this move in the
advanced french
but at this level it's all about
understanding when you violate the rules
that's how you
beat people at this level a6 okay this
gives us an opportunity for a very good
move
whenever you have a knight on c3 and a
queen on b6
uh there's a particular move that you
should always think about it's it's
something you can beat into your head
and that move is knight a4
what is the idea what's the follow-up to
this move the follow-up is to play
knight takes e5 and now we have rooted
out this very important dark square
bishop we've got the two bishops now
we've got an amazing position
two bishops black's position is kind of
positionally in shambles
there's many ways to play this
uh we can choose a very aggressive
approach and let's say play knight g5
we can now take on h6 because the
situation has changed quite a bit but i
still want to keep the bishop
um
i love the move knight g5 i feel like
it's aggressive
and
really forces black to
to decide what to do also c3 is good
let's play it more slowly
bishop e3 is great to develop with tempo
c3 is an excellent move here
to protect the d4 square that's
just very very typical
i mean i want to play this more
positionally
we are not afraid of knight g4 because
then we just go queen e2 and
we chase the knight away with h3
this is not a worrisome move
knight back to g8 wow
so he's rerouting the knight to e7 but
very very slow
so
how to punish something like this
well you don't necessarily need to
punish it um
we don't necessarily have to win this
game in one move
and just completing our development is a
good way to start so
getting the queen out of c5 bishop e3
queen a5
okay now
i think we can start we can continue
playing with tempo and gather important
squares for our pieces
let's go before
now what's the purpose of attacking the
queen it's not just to say that we
attack the queen we are establishing a
very important stronghold one could even
say an outpost for one of our pieces
what am i talking about
bishop c5 yeah it it just slices right
down this important diagonal the bishop
could park itself on d6 there's no hurry
in doing that we can do that right now
we can do that a bit later
let's get it out of the way
let's go bishop d6 just to
park that bishop right in his gut
and now i think once the queen
moves away
a great time arises for
more concrete aggressive action so what
move
represents the start of earth how do we
start our attack on the king's side what
is it now time for because we've made
all the improvements we have a great
bishop here we've completed our
development and it's very natural to
transition now
into something
more concrete and aggressive and that
would be knight g5 and queen h5
we are going for
instacheckmate here
yeah
i think this is just
very bad for black
well i don't see what rook c1 would do
though
you're trying to prepare c4 i guess
that's
an alternate plan for sure but i think
playing on the king side makes more
sense here because we are just hunting
for black's king
no but castling
castling is impossible okay knight g6
all right
let's get the lady in
ah he has this good move though
we might need more more heat in the
attack knight d8
all right
knight d8 is a decisive mistake i'm
pretty sure
so what should we do here
does anybody see a very strong move that
i think wins the game
the first thing i see is bishop takes g6
which almost works
it does not work because if f takes g6
um but notice the relationship between
the queen and the rook so what we do is
we take on h7 here but not just to say
that we want a pawn rather
we are preparing bishop takes g6 we're
taking a defender off of the knight
if this knight moves then we have knight
f6 check exposing
the attack on the rook so knight d8 was
way too passive
i think 97 was black's last chance
yeah his queen is nowhere to be found
and black's position
totally collapses here
now knight takes f7 did not work because
he would have taken the knight and then
the rook would have been defended twice
so you got to be very careful in such
positions
yeah very functional very functional
move knight takes h7 it's not not gonna
win a brilliant surprise but it's gonna
win the game
i just don't think there's a defense i
don't think he played like a 1400 i
think he played well in the opening
and once he blundered knight a4
he started tilting
i don't think this guy played like a
1400
i mean he made some very weird moves
like knight g8 was too slow
inviting b4 was bad
but
not an easy position to defend
yeah he's thinking but
queen takes c3
all right so the wind here quite is
quite elementary obviously
do not go knight f6 here because if g
takes f6 first we have to take the uh
take the knight
and the second thing is don't rush
through these moments because uh in
making automatic moves
uh you often
forgo opportunities to win the game
in a much more efficient way
this is gigi in fact after f takes g6 we
have many different we have two
different ways to win
and i think they both
end the game almost immediately
he resigns
okay so just real fast
yeah he says gg i'll say gg
just real fast um
after f takes g6 i think the simplest is
queen takes g6 knight f7
and now knight comes back to g5
and this bishop is the hero because
there's no recafe
so black loses the knight and
essentially just gets checkmated easy
stuff
uh the second win
is to go knight f6 check
this is also basically mate if he takes
then it's made
black should play king f7 but queen
takes h8 and
the mate threat is unstoppable
okay simple game
so this line knight f3
um
highly recommended for players
in most writing categories really below
below titled
um so this was first played let's see
this was first played in the year
um
i think sometime in the 1800s
this was played in the year on 1826 by
nn and then
uh nimsovich played it like seven times
thank you junior all we need
nimzovich played it a ton because he
understood the concepts
uh the most famous line here is c takes
c4
now you play bishop d3
so let's say black develops normally why
are we like what is the purpose of this
well it's not so easy for black to
develop here
because if you play bishop c5
white goes rookie one knight g7
knight bd2 and first of all if black is
not is not careful
this move already loses
we can start with knight b3 to chase the
bishop
and now in comes the greek gift
sacrifice this is a classic re-gift a
lot of games have ended this way
i've had some students
win games
very very similar way
so obviously black should start with
knight g6
to block the influence of the bishop
right
but
now we go knight b3 we get the knight to
a nice square
and if bishop b6 then at our leisure we
could recover the pawn we could play
bishop takes g6 and knight b takes d4
and white gets a very nice blockade here
on the square maybe not immediately
first we should start with h3
um and
black actually i think needs to be quite
precise to keep equality
um
but why not knight before to take the
bishop on d3 so if black plays knight
before we can always dip the bishop back
to f1 it's not
doesn't need to be on d3 all the time
then we play a3
the knight is not going to be stable on
b4
see takes d4 is the most popular yeah so
i'm sure if you look this up with
stockfish you could find a better
arrangement of pieces for black maybe
black should go queen b6
i think the way our opponent played was
quite quite astute
just not taking the pawn at all
and here i think that i played it
incorrectly
it looks like dc yields an advantage we
should just get rid of that pawn
and then play either knight c3 or play
the movie played in the game c3
establishing control over the d4 square
and then again
the knight can maneuver its way to b3
ultimately we are aiming for control of
d4
which gives us a nice bind over black's
position slight advantage for white
for some reason i didn't i wanted to
preserve the spirit of the line rookie
one
so
i think a lot of people would be afraid
of c4 but this is a classic example of
being afraid of a move just because it
forces a piece back so ask yourself why
are you afraid of c4
and you'll see that the only real reason
you're afraid of it is because it forces
the bishop back but if you know that
retreating moves are not inherently bad
c4 stops being scary just get the bishop
back
then at your leisure you could play b3
and cut into this pawn chain
in addition you can play c3 and build up
a pawn chain of your own this pawn on e5
gives white a big advantage
because it stops black from developing
his pieces to natural squares
yeah c4 also kills black's queen side
game and if you play c3 you make this
queen side and knight look very very
queen and knight look very stupid
okay hopefully that makes sense knight
h6 knight c3
and here comes i think almost the
decisive mistake a6
at this point black absolutely should
take on d4
knight b5
and probably go knight f5 something to
this effect
uh to try to stop knight d6 tracking
yeah i was thinking of going g4 here
but according to the computer black
encounter attack our knight with a6 very
unclear position
messi gf a b knight g5 i love these
positions though queen is coming out to
h5 i think white's position is more fun
to play here
so i think the move knight c3 is
actually really really good
yeah the engine really likes it too
a6 and now knight a4 is pretty
devastating because it forces black to
get rid of the bishop
yeah c3
is also approved of
um just establishing control over the
square and knight g8 is just uh
you know kind of tilt i think knight f5
probably gives black a more playable
position
but um
yeah if you want to know how to play
this line you can study the nimsevich
games
so nimizovich buggle yuba from 1920 is a
very good
illustration of how how it can go wrong
for black nimbus spielman from 1920.
just look up nimzovich's games
in this line that will be a good start
thank you juliafig123
for the five gifted subs much
appreciated
um
yeah knight g8 develop
attack
outpost
and now knight g5 typical queen h5
okay so here knight c to e7 i think
yielded the most chances
but now i was planning a rook lift
rookie 3 rook f3 and i think the game is
over because
this is coming and
black's position is totally overwhelmed
okay we don't really care about this
move we can just
move the rook away
the game is over so this is a good line
i think that if you're looking for a
line against the french
definitely investigate
this line it's not very well studied
um you can build yourself a nice
you know nice niche this line
yeah we had queen f3 instead of queen h5
probably more accurate
probably more accurate to go queen f3
although still knight d8
and even here we have knight h7
beautiful move
takes takes and if he takes then it's me
um
no bishop e7 just king e7 and black is
fine
you don't want to let black coordinate
you don't want to give this bishop away
unless it's for a good
cause no this is fine for black
okay
um that was a good solid way to end the
stream i think
i gotta get going thank you guys thanks
for hanging out i had a good time hope
you did as well see you guys tomorrow
later
[Music]